How often have you encountered orchids?
I've never seen an Orca.
Really?
No,
no,
no.
I mean not other than sea world's kidnapping of them.
Foxy world.
Yeah,
I'm with Ya.
I just don't understand.
I mean I,
I guess I understand cause I was a kid once and I went there,
but I don't understand how a rational,
logical thinking adult could take their kids to see world after all the
information that's out there about,
about their social behaviors,
about how smart these animals are about how got into a lot of people.
Unfortunately.
I know.
Yeah,
I agree with you if you did get the information,
but a lot of people just don't know.
They think well they're,
they're fed,
they're healthy.
Bowls are nice.
Yeah,
they don't,
yeah.
I got in this battle with a,
and look,
I'm no scientist.
I debate people all the time,
but I'm no scientist obviously.
I just,
I think I have a pretty good heart and I feel bad for animals that are locked up
that need to travel a hundred miles a day in their social packs and they need to
have interaction with other animals.
And they need a certain amount of space.
I mean,
imagine you think about solitary confinement for a prison.
New Guy,
a prisoner who's,
who's in,
who's in a room that's no wider than they are tall and maybe twice as twice as
long as they are tall,
you know,
and,
and there's no interaction with other people.
They go crazy.
Most people come out of prisons and jails worse than they went in because of
this kind of thing that happens to him.
But think of being in there for 30 years,
just wondering,
God,
is there another whale and the other side of that wall,
can I get some fish?
Can I mean go nuts?
And you see these videos that the trainer that was killed,
um,
and a trainer,
one trainer,
luckily the guy is a great free diver and he lived through a,
basically an attack by an Orca.
And the thing knew he wanted to get over to that wall and he went,
Nope,
I'm not gonna.
I'm gonna play with you and I'm just going to keep pulling you down and pulling
you down.
And the guy was good enough free diver to be able to know,
okay,
I've got to conserve my energy.
I got to bring my heart rate down.
I'm going to have to have to hold my breath against my will when I don't know
what's going to happen.
A friend of mine used to work at marine land in Canada.
My friend Phil,
Phil Demars and he was an orchid trainer and you know,
and he's trying to get marine land closed down.
There's this big lawsuit with them and he's been involved in a lawsuit with them
for over five years now.
I was just hanging out with him in Toronto and he was a Walrus trainer and this
is Walrus that he was taken care of.
It's the only one that's left there that survived and marine land is like slowly
going bankrupt.
The guy who was the original owners now quickly go bankrupt.
So it's so dark,
man.
The whole,
the whole business is so dark because you know,
a lot of them say,
oh,
we won't take any,
you know,
orcas are dolphins from captivity,
but they'll get them from people that stole them in the wild and they,
they,
uh,
breed.
You know,
I think there's no more breeding a lot in America,
but they'll get them from someone that bred them in Canada or Russia rather or
China or where some place where there's not as many rules.
You know,
John Lilly,
who was the guy who actually invented the isolation tank is a,
he was a pioneer and interspecies communication,
which is a,
it's a weird field.
He was a scientist.
That was also,
he took like extreme liberties with his scientific research,
took a lot of acid,
gave it acid to dolphins,
did a lot of Dolphin Research in the flotation tank,
did a lot of really,
really wacky shit.
But he believed that one day dolphins were going to have a seat in the United
Nations.
He believe we're going to be able to communicate with dolphins and that dolphins
were going to be recognized as water people.
He thought they were going to be literally the thought there was smartest human
beings.
Amazing.
If we could figure out how to communicate with them,
they would have the same rights as human beings.
Yeah,
and guy was a genius.
I mean just he and I,
I agree with them.
I think there's just a level of communication.
There's a way that they have of communicating that we don't understand,
but it's a super complex.
If their own dialects they have,
they,
they have this crazy social code.
I mean they,
they have something like incredibly dynamic about their,
their environment and their,
their,
you know,
their social groups.
To be,
to be able to speak a language,
you need to know like 150 words.
There was a dolphin that new like 700 words,
300 words,
I don't know,
hundreds like command standard human words.
You know how many dolphin warrants we know zero.
I'll fucking clue.
We have no idea.
We don't know what the fuck they're saying,
but they're so goddamn stupid.
Fucking stop giving me macro level.
They're like,
they don't know.
We're making fun of them for hundreds of years.
I don't think they know what to do with them.
Well,
one of the things that Phil was working with was there's a group,
what was that group that where they're trying to,
they're going to create a boundary dri out in the ocean and slowly released
these dolphins and orchestras out into this boundary and then you know,
and keep feeding them.
But then lowly released them out to the ocean per open ocean pens.
Yeah.
They're talking about doing that possibly.
And that would be a way for people to actually experience it because it,
the idea is that you and I had a debate with his trainer.
I watched blackfish and it just freaked me out.
And of course it's,
there's probably a lot of confirmation bias.
There's probably some information in there that is not totally unbiased.
Right.
Obviously they're trying to make a point.
But this one was,
she talked to all the different trainers and stuff.
I got in contact,
a guy got in contact with me that was a trainer and he said,
Kelly,
the whole movie is Bs.
Um,
I think,
I believe this guy was actually in the movie.
He's like,
it was all bs.
Orcas live longer in in captivity and indeed they do in the wild.
He told me that
orcas haven't been in captivity as long as they live yet,
so we don't know that.
So that's completely a lie.
It's,
he has no idea if that's true.
He said they're more healthy.
He told me all these things and I just finally went,
this guy's just full of I,
I dunno,
I,
I can't buy what he's telling me.
And he,
but he said,
I'm a trainer.
I've been a trainer for it.
I looked him up and bias because that's where he makes his living.
Exactly.
And I know some dolphin trainers and I actually went to sea world a few times in
Australia.
I used to know a few of the trainers back in the late nineties and I went there
a few times when with the dolphins.
The first day I was there,
one of the things I asked him was like,
do they,
will these guys ever get set free and write down?
I could feel a little pull back,
you know,
like straight away.
I could feel like,
oh,
maybe.
And I felt that release my slaves.
Yeah.
I felt a little uncomfortable with keep asking questions because it is their
livelihood and I had a respect for that.
And I know that all these trainers love these animals.
They really,
truly like,
probably love them more than they love the most people.
Um,
but that doesn't make it right.
Right.